bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur les chaînes parlementaires dans
quelques instants nous allons suivre les
voeux de françois hollande aux acteurs
de l'entreprise et de l'emploi le chef
de l'état qui ne devrait plus tarder à
faire son entrée dans cette salle de
l'élysée et pour commenter ses voeux
avec nous notre spécialiste économie que
jean louis gombeaud bonjour jean louis
mo jours reviennent et notre spécialiste
politique mais qu'elle aimait son genre
en 15 jours alors michael a après une
semaine marquée par les événements que
l'on connaît françois hollande reprend
une activité plus normal et cette
traditionnelle cérémonie des voeux
oui c'est montrer un petit peu que la
vie continue il y aura plusieurs points
il faut cultiver cet esprit du rouleau
janvier ils valent certainement le
répéter et c'est très important il l'a
fait déjà en corrèze c'était samedi
dernier montré également que les
problèmes n'ont pas changé même si la
vie continue et une autre façon il va
falloir aussi appelle faire un appel à
une certaine responsabilité des chefs
d'entreprise on lancera rappel l'année
dernière de cette proposition de pacte
de responsabilité cette fois c'est faire
preuve de responsabilité par rapport aux
événements mais surtout garder cet
esprit du duo janvier qu'il va lui
permettre aussi également de deux dalles
et un petit peu plus loin sur les enjeux
économiques et de montrer que finalement
il n'y a pas de polémique politicienne
mais qu'au contraire tout le monde doit
oeuvrer dans le même sens jean louis on
voit l'emploi et la crise reste au coeur
des préoccupations des français on a
entendu françois hollande interpellé sur
ces sujets samedi en corrèze
alors les questions économiques et
sociales seront le lendemain du 11
janvier c'est à dire que l'on janvier
quelque part c'est quand même une
parenthèse mais avec plusieurs aspects
qui ont des rapports avec les questions
économiques et sociales notamment il ya
un problème sur la confiance la sécurité
d'ores et déjà vous si vous regardez le
début des soldes et c'est pas ça se
passe mal l'activité commerciale se
passe malgré l'aspect quel est le
rapport avec ce qui s'est passé en
matière d' attentat il ya une quinzaine
de jours je ne peux pas vous le dire
mais en tout cas on a besoin de
retrouver un certain climat de sérénité
de sécurité de confiance
même au sein des entreprises beaucoup
d'entreprises par exemple disent de plus
en plus
nous sommes de plus en plus heurté
interpellé sur des questions
communautaires à l'inter les entreprises
donc ça concerne quand même ce qui s'est
passé le au monde ce qui s'est passé le
toute cette tendance concerne quand même
directement les entreprises
ensuite le président de la république
lors de ses voeux avait placé ses voeux
sur la question de l'offensive du
dynamisme
il va devoir maintenant je crois la
placer sur la question de la confiance
peut dire reprenaient confiance il n'y a
pas une situation aussi dramatique et
vous pouvez reprendre confiance les
investisseurs
vous pouvez créer des emplois depuis le
1er janvier est entré une nouvelle étape
nous avions eu le cce qu'être qui a
démarré l'année dernière et qui
maintenant est rempli non pas remplacer
mais auquel on ajoute le pacte de
stabilité
depuis le 1er janvier un certain nombre
de rendez vous importants vont avoir
lieu dans les semaines les mois qui
viennent notamment entre le patronat et
les syndicats sur la question du
dialogue social qui s'est achevée à
achever interrompu la semaine dernière
sur un échec et qui doit reprendre dans
les jours qui viennent
ensuite il ya tout le débat qui va
arriver dès le mois de février sur la
question des retraites
sachant que ceux sur ce fonds là les
retraites complémentaires se fout là la
situation économique se complique
vous prenez l'année 2014 elle est
vraiment moins bolt 2013
vous avez une conjoncture certes de
croissance de 0 4%
la même chose qu'en 2013 ou en 2014 le
chômage a augmenté 180000 les déficits
publics comptent augmenter la dette
publique a augmenté donc les gros
problèmes sont toujours là et beaucoup
plus compliqué qu'il ne l'était il ya
encore un an donc sans problème à
monsieur le problème de monsieur
hollande ce sera de dire vous pouvez
avoir confiance
nous avons mis en place des systèmes qui
vont permettre une petite reprise dans
un premier temps donc l'horizon est
quelque peu dégagé il va falloir
démontrer ce qu'ils appellent
chez les conseillers c'est ce qu'ils
appellent le trou de souris là qu'ils
ont vu qu'il y avait un petit espace
depuis depuis quelques mois de deux mois
à peu près avant les fêtes où la
croissance ramenée un tout petit peu il
y avait quelques signes notamment de
l'insee qui apportait quelques bonnes
nouvelles
là il voit un espace est ce qu'ils
aimeraient c'est à grandir ce trou de
souris
on le voit aussi par rapport aux prix du
pétrole par rapport au prix de l'euro
près tout ça ce sont des petites
conjoncture des petits points positifs
que veut engranger françois hollande et
qui évidemment va se servir de cela
auprès des chefs d'entreprise pour dire
comme il dit jugeant lui confiance ayez
confiance
il ya un domaine dans lequel lindsay n'a
pas apporté de bonnes nouvelles c'est le
domaine du chômage en janvier puisque
selon les prévisions de l'insee le
chômage continuera à augmenter au moins
jusqu'à mi 2015
oui alors l'unedic eux a même donné des
chiffres plus précis vendredi 105 mille
chômeurs de plus en 2015
si ces 105 mille chômeurs de plus en
2015 c'est quand même une augmentation
moins forte qu'en 2014 où on est on n'a
pas encore les chiffres de décembre on
les aura la semaine prochaine
180 milles peut-être 190 mille chômeurs
de plus d'eau on va pas on va pas
trouver ça une bonne nouvelle mais bon
quelque part en tout cas il est clair
que le pacte de responsabilité qui est
en contre et en vigueur au début janvier
ne va pas inverser en tout cas pour l'un
2015 cette fameuse courbe du chômage
enfin si les prévisions de l'unedic
s'avère vrai si ce que nous a dit
l'insee effectivement il ya à peu près
un mois le taux de chômage va dépasser
les 10% et donc les 105 milles de que
prévoit l'unedic vendredi
il n'y a pas d' inversion de la courbe
du chômage
et d'ailleurs vous avez remarqué que
dans les dernière prévisions par rapport
à aux effets positifs corps a
incontestablement le pacte de
responsabilité bien entendu et
d'ailleurs ça sera un aspect important
je pense de l'intervention du président
de la république dire combien de
branches ont signé on est à huit pour
l'instant combien de branches ont signé
des accords avec les syndicats pour en
échange des baisses de charges dont
elles vont bénéficier créer des emplois
ça c'est une question importante on ne
connait pas vers la réponse précise même
si on sait que les désaccords sont
relativement faibles
ceci ne permet pas de
d'inverser réellement la cause du
chômage alors 2016 2007 2016 2017 c'est
autre chose mais vous avez remarqué qu'
il n'y a plus d'objectifs chiffrés
au début on parlait de cinq cent mille
emplois créés grâce au cic eux opaques
de responsabilité aujourd'hui on est un
petit peu plus mesuré ou tel point
d'ailleurs qu'on avance plus trop de
chiffres donc 2015 ne s'annoncent pas
sous un jour tellement favorable malgré
ce qu'a rappelé tout à l'heure michael
que l'insee nous dit on va avoir 0 3% de
croissance au premier trimestre 0 3% de
croissance au deuxième trimestre on a
sur certains pour 2015 0 17% et sans
doute pourra-t-on atteint 2 1% prévus
par le gouvernement
s'ajoute à cela la baisse de l'euro et
la baisse du prix du pétrole qui
pourrait apporter 0 5-0 6% de croissance
supplémentaire non prévus on atteindrait
alors fort 2015 ce fameux 1 5% qui doit
aider à créer des emplois nets à michael
politiquement la non en version de la
combustion compliqué toute façon ça fait
plus d'un an que maintenant françois
hollande le sait il avait dit lui-même
que cette inversion de la courbe du
chômage
il n'y arriverait pas finalement c'est
assez c'était un échec annoncé de ce
qu'il avait promis au début de début de
son quinquennat
ce qui est sûr et certain c'est que 2015
ce sera une année très difficile pour
françois hollande il ya des élections
très important qu'il ya des élections
départementales il ya des élections
régionales qui visiblement ne seront pas
une réussite c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire pour le parti socialiste pour la
gauche en général
et puis sur le plan économique et social
pas ce sont deux fronts très compliqué
pour le président de la république il a
beau avoir récupéré des points dans les
sondages après les événements de la
semaine dernière sur l'aspect économique
et social ce sera beaucoup plus
compliqué c'est que s'il a grappillé
quelques points dans les sondages à mon
avis à partir du moment où on va rentrer
dans le vif du sujet sur les questions
économiques et sociales que les français
vont se comprendre à nouveau que cette
inversion de la courbe du chômage
n'arrivera pas après les annonces que
veut nous donner
jean-louis en terme de points ce sera un
peu plus compliqué pour françois
hollande
voilà le président de la république qui
est en train de faire son entrée dans
cette salle de l'élysée pour je vous le
rappelle présenter ses voeux aux acteurs
de l'entreprise et de l'emploi on écoute
tout de suite en direct le chef des
messieurs le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président du conseil économique social
et environnemental
mesdames messieurs qui représentait les
forces vives une nation c'est d'abord
des institutions ces institutions ont
montré leur force leur solidité face à
l' attaque terroriste qui a frappé notre
pays avec un état qui a pris les
décisions qui convenait avec des forces
de police de gendarmerie qui ont fait la
démonstration de leur efficacité avec
une armée qui était prête à mettre dans
un délai très rapide des hommes et des
femmes pour protéger les français sur
l'ensemble du territoire une nation
c'est un parlement avec des forces
politiques qui ont été capables de se
réunir sur l'essentiel dans un moment
grave pour notre pays une unité
nationale qui a été salué ici et bien
au-delà de nos frontières
une nation ce sont des forces
économiques et sociales et voulait
représenter ici au titre des entreprises
petites moyennes et grandes de tous les
secteurs au titre des salariés avec vos
différentes organisations
vous êtes les forces vives de la nation
celle qui produisent craie innove
investissent celles qui permettent que
des emplois puissent être créées emplois
indispensables à l'équilibré de notre
société
vous êtes et forces vives qui permettait
le progrès qu'il soit économique social
environnemental
vous produisez des richesses et vous
faites s'en sort par le dialogue la
négociation
qu'elles soient équitablement répartis
vous êtes des forces qui favorise
l'intégration par le travail par la
réussite et par l'espoir d'être
pleinement pour celles et ceux qui
composent notre société des citoyens une
nation c'est un peuple le peuple
français a su répondre à l'agression
dont il était la cible par une
mobilisation républicaine sans précédent
il a exprimé son attachement à des
valeurs qui fondent notre pays il ne
s'est pas laissée emporter par la peur
il a refusé les amalgames il a rappelé
la force et la place de la laïcité de la
fraternité pour assurer notre vie
ensemble
c'est cette même nation qui doit après
l'épreuve qu'elle a surmonté avec fierté
d'inité unité
si cette même nation qui doit se
retrouver aujourd'hui pour donner à
notre pays la force économique qui lui
permettra à la fois de peser sur la
scène mondiale et d'offrir un avenir à
chacun de nos concitoyens je sais que
vous avez cette responsabilité au coeur
et je sais que vous veillerez dans les
décisions que vous aurez à prendre dans
les prochains jours prochaines semaines
prochains mois à être vous aussi à la
hauteur de ce qui s'est produit dans
notre pays
nous avons quatre ambitions si je
reviens à ce qu'est la vie économique de
notre pays
la compétitivité l'innovation
l'attractivité et la transition
énergétique
il y a un an j'annonçais le pacte de
responsabilité et de solidarité
il ya eu des discussions d'abord entre
les forces sociales et économiques
ensuite au parlement dans le pays mais
aujourd'hui le pacte est une réalité
l'état y consacre 40 milliards à
l'horizon de 2017 40 milliards c'est une
somme considérable au regard de la
situation de nos finances publiques nous
aurions pu hésiter
nous aurions pu fléchir nous avons tenu
bon
ces deux points de la richesse nationale
qui vont être ainsi transférer 2015 ce
sera la première année de versement du
cice crédit impôt compétitivité emploi à
taux plein -c'est-à-dire 6 % un taux
d'ailleurs plus élevé en outre-mer 2015
c'est aussi la première année au les
cotisations sociales vont être allégée
et qu'un dispositif zéro charge au
niveau du smic sera créé 2015
c'est aussi l'année où l'impôt sur
revenu destinée aux ménages de catégorie
moyenne et modeste va être allégé 9
millions de français sont concernés
quel objectif c'est l'emploi
avec comme levier la restauration des
marges des entreprises nécessaires pour
relancer l'investissement
la hausse du pouvoir d'achat afin de
soutenir la consommation et la
négociation collective dans les branches
pour favoriser les embauches
la priorité de 2015 y compris et surtout
après ce que nous avons vécu c'est
d'assurer la sécurité de nos concitoyens
mais c'est aussi et toujours l'emploi
parce que notre pays compte plus de
trois millions quatre cent mille
chômeurs parmi lesquelles un jeune de
moins de 25 ans sur cinq est dans cette
situation le chômage c'est une menace
pour la cohésion de notre pays
alors il convient que chacun y prennent
sapin un impact suppose des
contreparties celles ci ont été inscrits
dans le relevé de conclusions de mars
un mouvement est engagé onze branches
représentant 4 millions de salariés ont
abouti à un accord
mais ce rythme est encore trop lents
beaucoup d'autres branches devront donc
prendre le chemin et accélérer la marche
l'enjeu c'est aussi et surtout la
reprise de la croissance
s'il n'y a pas de croissance il n'y aura
pas d'emplois
malgré toutes les mesures que nous
pouvons déployer donc ce que nous avons
à faire ensemble dans un contexte que je
vais décrire c'est le porter la priorité
de la croissance et donc de
l'investissement et donc de l'innovation
et donc aussi du dialogue social quel
environnement que nous connaissons il a
changé ces dernières semaines le prix du
baril de pétrole a baissé de 60% en six
mois
est ce que nous pourrions nous poser une
question est si le prix du pétrole
avaient augmenté de 60% depuis six mois
que dirions-nous donc il s'est produit
ce qu'on appelle un contre choc
pétrolier les prix à la pompe ont
diminué de 20 centimes par litre depuis
cet été
qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit s'ils avaient
augmenté de 20 centimes par litre donc
il y à une amélioration du pouvoir
d'achat des ménages est également des
marges des entreprises notamment celles
qui utilisent beaucoup d'énergie pour
fabriquer leurs produits ou qui
sur des entreprises de transport qui ont
là des baisses de coût tout à fait
significative des incertitudes demeurent
et c'est bien légitime sur le caractère
durable de ce niveau de prix ce que nous
pouvons dire c'est que ces prix
traduisent un déséquilibre entre l'offre
et la demande sur le marché pétrolier
mondial qui ne disparaîtra pas
rapidement
il convient donc que ce soit pour les
entreprises ou pour les ménages
d'intégrer dans nos prévisions pour
l'année que les prix du pétrole vont
rester à un niveau plus faible qu'en
2014 et sans doute au niveau actuel
deuxième paramètre les taux d'intérêt
ils ont atteint des niveaux
historiquement bas
non pas qu'il n'y ait pas d'incertitude
là aussi sur les marchés non pas qu'il y
ait des doutes qui aurait disparu comme
par enchantement
en tout cas il y a une crédibilité de la
signature de la france puisque elle ne
s'est jamais financé pour ses
obligations souveraines à des taux aussi
faible 0 7% à 10 ans c'était le taux qui
était demandé vendredi dernier
ce qui est aussi une conséquence pour
l'ensemble des crédits à l'économie
c'est en france d'ailleurs que les
crédits à l'économie ont le plus
progressé en 2014 par rapport aux autres
pays européens
mais est-ce à dire que toutes les
entreprises peuvent accéder au crédit
pas encore et c'est à dire que pour
certaines entreprises c'est plus
difficile de trouver des capitaux
oui toujours et donc nous devons faire
en sorte qu'il y ait non seulement plus
de crédit c'est le rôle des banques à
des taux toujours aussi faible mais
qu'il y est également plus d'accès aux
capitaux pour les entreprises qui
veulent financer leurs investissements
quant à l'euro
de nombreux débats ont lieu en france
sur son bon niveau mais faire un débat
n'est pas prendre la décision mais je
constate qu'aujourd'hui le niveau de
l'euro est revenu à son cours d'il ya 15
ans et que ça a des conséquences sur la
compétitivité d'ailleurs de même ampleur
que le pacte de responsabilité et de
solidarité
est ce que cette baisse de l'euro va
produire notamment pour des secteurs
comme l'aéronautique la chimie
l'agroalimentaire
ça va avoir des conséquences si nous
savons les suivre en termes
d'amélioration de notre balance
commerciale et donc d'augmentation de
notre production est également si nous
accompagnons ce processus en termes
d'emploi tous ces facteurs me confirme
que le gouvernement a eu raison de fixer
une prévision de croissance de l'ordre
de 1% pour l'année 2015
et c'est ce que d'ailleurs un certain
nombre d'organismes internationaux
confirmeront mais nous devons aussi être
lucides et ne pas tout attendre d'un
environnement international
nous nous connaissons les fluctuations
la situation économique de l'europe
demeure encore sujette à interrogations
l'inflation atteint des niveaux
tellement faible qu'on pense même qu'on
est en dessous c'est à dire qu'on a des
risques de déflation ce qui a comme
conséquence de créer de provoquer des
anticipations qui sont défavorables à
l'activité chacun peut le comprendre si
on pense que les prix vont encore
baisser pourquoi acheter aujourd'hui
pourquoi investir alors reporté pour les
mois qui viennent et c'est cette
attitude là c'est cette anticipation la
qui peut être défavorable à la
croissance
ça c'est le premier facteur ensuite il
ya des facteurs géopolitiques
quand il ya des guerres quand il y à un
terrorisme il peut aussi y avoir de la
part d'un certain nombre de
ea ou d'investisseurs la décision de ne
pas acheter autant que par le passé ou
de voir un certain nombre de flux des
changes être affecté je suis préoccupé
par les conséquences de ce qui se passe
en ukraine
des sanctions qui ont été prononcés sur
la russie parce qu'on voit bien que
c'est toute cette région là qui est
affecté d'où l'intérêt que j'ai porté à
la résolution de la crise ukrainienne
mais aussi au maintien du dialogue avec
la russie également pour des raisons qui
tiennent à notre agriculture qui a été
largement affecté par ces sanctions
elle aussi est donc nous devons faire en
sorte que nous puissions régler les
questions du continent
et lorsque nous luttions contre le
terrorisme ou lorsque nous agissons pour
la paix nous agissons aussi pour
l'économie
parce qu'une façon de réduire les
incertitudes
c'est de faire que la france puisse être
utile à la paix troisième facteur nous
de ton une moindre croissance de la part
des pays émergents pas de tous mais de
certains notamment la chine et ça aussi
des conséquences sur la demande qui est
adressé à l'europe ou qui peut l'être à
notre pays premier ministre va bientôt
se rendre en chine très important que
nous puissions montrer que nous sommes
là justement quand cette économie
réfléchit à son avenir notamment pour la
transition énergétique et chaque fois
que un membre du gouvernement le premier
ministre ou que j'ai à le faire comme
chef de l'état nous déplaçons dans les
pays émergents nous devons avec vous
forces économiques forces sociales
apporter ce que la france peut donner
comme contribution à ces pays et comme
modèle et comme référence mais l'europe
dans ce contexte doit faire preuve de
plus d'initiatives
il y a le plan juncker 315 milliards
d'euros pour des investissements et
c'est un pas très important nous l'avons
rappelé nous n'allons pas aujourd'hui
faire la moue nous avons
que à faire en sorte que son exécution
puisse être traduite rapidement que des
investissements puissent être d'ores et
déjà lancée que des avances puisse être
faite aux entreprises ou aux états qui
pourraient se lancer dans ce type
d'investissement convient également que
les contributions nationales puissent
être ajoutés et que ces contributions
nationales ne figure plus dans le pacte
de stabilité pour que nous ayons un
effet de levier en termes
d'investissements la commission a
commencé de nous entendre sur cette
question de la même manière les
flexibilités qui sont prévus par le
pacte de stabilité doivent être
entièrement utilisée pour fixer le bon
rythme de réduction des déficits publics
sans pour autant renoncer à maîtriser la
dépense
au contraire nous aurons à faire des
économies en 2015 et en 2016
en 2007 sans toucher à l'essentiel de
nos services publics ce qui suppose
là encore de faire preuve d'innovation
enfin la banque centrale européenne val
je dis prendre la décision de racheter
des dettes souveraines ce qui va donner
des liquidités importantes à l'économie
européenne
et là aussi peut créer un mouvement
favorable à la croissance
dans ce contexte tout ne relève pas de
l'europe et n'attendons pas d'elle ce
qui ne peut pas être fait à son niveau
mais qui doit être engagée au nôtre nous
devons donc on aucune façon réduire nos
efforts pour moderniser notre économie
réformée nos modes de production
réorganiser aussi le travail dans notre
pays
d'abord nous devons faire en sorte que
tout soit préservée pour l'insertion des
chômeurs de longue durée et des jeunes
c'est une question très importante pour
la cohésion nationale
alors les emplois aidés continuerons à
mobiliser notre attention malgré les
difficultés budgétaires 380 mille
personnes les plus éloignées du marché
du travail seront concernés en 2015 le
contrat de génération qui a mis du temps
pour se déployer a déjà donné lieu à
2500 accord est d'ailleurs beaucoup de
ces accords peuvent se trouver dans les
discussions de branche pour le pacte de
responsabilité et beaucoup d'entreprises
peuvent utiliser le contrat de
génération à cette fin le système a été
assouplie notamment pour encourager
l'embauché des seniors et pour que ce
soit pas simplement du côté des jeunes
mais aussi du côté des seniors dans
l'emploi ou hors de l'emploi que nous
puissions utiliser le mécanisme et que
ce soit plus simple pour les pme
toujours plus simple parce que chaque
fois que l'on peut faire ça évitons de
faire compliqué c'est à grands principes
de l'action publique mais hélas trop peu
traduit dans la réalité il ya également
les emplois d'avenir 85 mille nouveaux
jeunes ont été embauchés en 2014 cent
mille l'avait été en 2013 seront 65
milles à être embauchés en 2015 ce
mouvement doit continuer car il concerne
les jeunes qui sont les plus éloignés du
marché du travail
on y ajoutera même un nouveau dispositif
les garanties jeunes pour 50000 en 2015
ils seront cent mille en 2010 est là il
s'agit de ces jeunes qui sont plus qu
éloignés du marché du travail qui se
pressent quand séparation en rupture
c'est vers ces jeunes que nous devons
aller pour aller les chercher les formes
et les qualifier les remettent dans
l'entreprise leur fixer des règles et je
crois que c'est encore plus
pourtant dans le mouvement que nous
vivons et puis il y a une valeur qui est
sorti est plus forte encore de ces
derniers jours l'engagement l'engagement
ça vaut pour tous mais l'engagement ça
doit être aussi pour des jeunes de
pouvoir être utile servir les autres ça
s'appelle le service civique
notre objectif c'est d'atteindre 100
mille volontaires le plus vite possible
et 150000 à l'horizon 2017 avec un
principe simple que tous les jeunes qui
en feront la demande puisse bénéficier
d'un service civique
quand j'ai dit bénéficier je me trompe
de mots faire bénéficier les autres de
ce service civique
l'engagement ça doit être une grande
formule non pas simplement de
circonstances mais pour que des jeunes
et même des moins jeunes prendre à
élargir puissent être pleinement
mobilisé pour l'intérêt général
l'année 2014 avait été marquée par une
avancée sociale majeure
toujours dans cette perspective d'emploi
le compte personnel de formation depuis
le 1er janvier 2015
la portabilité des droits à formation
est effective il donne à tous les
salariés un outil d'évaluation pour
mesurer ses compétences professionnelles
tout au long de sa vie et donc les
possibilités de se requalifier de se
remettre sur le marché du travail dans
ce qu'il en a été écarté et ces
droits-là lui appartiennent aux salariés
et il pourra se salarier avec les
évolutions qui sont liées aux
changements d'emploi pouvoir toujours
les garder comme un capital dès lors
qu'il peut l'utiliser en 2014 j'avais
lancé l'opération formation prioritaire
pour l'emploi c'est à dire faire que les
angles les offres d'emploi non pourvues
puisse l'être avec une formation qui
pourrait être apportée à des demandeurs
d'emploi
quatre-vingt mille demandeurs d'emploi
ont été concernés en 2014 c'est un quasi
triplement par rapport à ce qui existait
en 2013
je salue tous ceux qui ont permis cette
mobilisation eh bien il aura sans bill
de ces demandeurs d'emploi qui seront
donc formé pour aller vers les offres
d'emploi des entreprises qui ne sont pas
pourvus en 2015
il y aura également une mobilisation
nationale pour l'apprentissage
c'avait été l'objet d'une concertation
est unanimement forces économiques
forces sociales avait considéré que
l'apprentissage devait être une voie une
voie d'excellence pour beaucoup de
jeunes
les aides ont été doublées pour les tpe
puisque ça peut remonter maintenant 2000
euros par apprenti une simplification
est intervenu pour l'accueil des
apprentis dans l'entreprise et pour leur
travail
une campagne de communication nationale
va être lancé
elle a déjà eu quelques effets et l'état
lui aussi a été amené à montrer
l'exemple
il montrait le mauvais à lui de montrer
le bon puisque il n'accueillait que 700
jeunes en apprentissage
jusqu'à présent il y en aura dix mille
et les collectivités locales seront
également associés à ce processus
mais je suis devant vous et je veux
revenir sur le dialogue social
parce que c'est la méthode que j'ai
choisi pour réformer notre pays
il peut y en avoir d'autres il peut être
décidé de légiférer en toutes
circonstances sans concertation il a
même qui propose qu'ils puissent être
réformé par ordonnance autrefois c'était
par décret que ça pouvait s'imaginer
j'ai considéré que le dialogue social
était la bonne méthode et que ce n'était
pas une perte de temps
c'était même le respect que l'on devait
à l'ensemble des acteurs de la vie
économique et sociale
dès lors qu'ils prenaient leurs
responsabilités le dialogue social ce
n'est pas un accord général sur tous les
sujets le dialogue social respecte la
volonté de ceux qui s'y comme la
position de ceux qui ne signent pas le
dialogue social ce n'est pas non plus
pour les partenaires sociaux de pouvoir
décider sur le parlement puisqu'il est à
chaque fois
saisie pour validation dès lors que les
mesures qui sont concernés entre dans le
champ législatif
cette méthode elle a fonctionné à la
marche et plusieurs accords
interprofessionnels ont été conclus avec
des signataires parfois différents j'en
conviens contrat de génération
sécurisation de l'emploi formation
professionnelle qualité de vie au
travail
égalité professionnelle dans la fonction
publique entre les hommes et les femmes
est également un accord sur les
retraites complémentaires retraites
complémentaires qui vont être de nouveau
dans les mains des partenaires sociaux
comme il va y avoir de nouveau une
négociation sur la convention assurance
chômage même si il y avait eu un accord
au printemps dernier nous savons bien
qu'il conviendra d'y revenir à l'horizon
voilà ce qu'on était capable de faire
les partenaires sociaux le gouvernement
a tenu aussi à les consulter de manière
approfondie sur la réforme des retraites
c'est ainsi qu'a été dégagés le dossier
de la pénibilité
aujourd'hui les choses sont claires les
droits sont ouverts dès le 1er janvier
pour les salariés dès le 1er janvier de
cette année avec une mise en oeuvre
simple pour les entreprises et en
particulier pour les plus petites en
2015 pour quatre critères et en 2016
pour les autres ce doit être simple
parce que si ce n'est pas simple ça ne
se mettra pas en oeuvre tout simplement
les droits sont ouverts et les
mécanismes seront autant qu'il sera
possible simplifier je suis né au moins
conscients que les formes du dialogue
social doivent évoluer
d'abord la conférence sociale elle-même
qui était l'idée que nous avions lancée
au lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle de 2012 plutôt qu'une
grande réunion une fois par an qui
définit une feuille de route général
mieux vaudrait fixé plusieurs rendez
vous sur des thèmes précis avec des
préparations plus longue des échanges
plus direct
et des décisions plus rapides j'en fais
ici la proposition
le dialogue c'est aussi de faire que
notre démocratie sociale puisse être à
la hauteur des attentes qui sont portés
sur elle dans ces circonstances où la
démocratie politique a montré un sens
élevé de ses devoirs et de son unité la
démocratie sociale c'est un élément
majeur de notre cohésion nationale
tout l'enjeu de la négociation en cours
sur la modernisation du dialogue social
elle repose forcément sur un équilibre
une organisons plus clair plus simple
dans l'entreprise avec une instance
représentative principal est de plus
grande souplesse pour la négociation et
pour les salariés une meilleure
représentation dans les petites et
moyennes entreprises et des perspectives
professionnelles bien mieux garanties
pour les salariés engagés dans les
mandats
le sujet est difficile il touche à des
traditions des représentations et il est
néanmoins majeur c'est légitime que les
discussions soient avenue est longue
plus longue que prévu vous avez un
rendez vous jeudi
je pense que c'est le dernier un échec
aurait des conséquences qui ré bien au
delà de cette seule réforme parce que
comment poursuivre le dialogue social
si sur son organisation même il ne
serait pas possible d'aboutir à un
accord et de comptons pas sur le
législateur pour traduire les voeux des
uns et des autres alors que les
partenaires sociaux n'aurait pas réussi
à conclure
ne vendons pas à la démocratie politique
de régler ce que la démocratie sociale
ne serait pas capable de faire elle-même
en revanche un accord s'il intervenait
ce qui est votre rôle
un accord
s'ils se concluaient y compris dans ces
circonstances ce serait un bel exemple
n'ont pas d'unanimité
car le dialogue social n'est pas la
confusion des intérêts mais un exemple
un exemple de compromis pour moderniser
le pays
pour pérenniser le dialogue pour me le
disait la négociation pour moderniser
les entreprises aussi la bonne adhésion
n'est pas qu'économique
elle est aussi sociale je devrais dire
elles mêmes culturel politique
c'est ce que nous avons à faire ensemble
alors la modernisation de notre économie
elle est aussi notre priorité
il s'agit de la rendre à la fois plus
performante plus agile plus créatrices
d'emplois qu'il y ait plus
d'opportunités qui puisse être saisie
notamment avec cette révolution
industrielle qui est à l'oeuvre sous nos
yeux avec le numérique et c'est le sens
aussi de la loi croissance activité
je les dis c'est toi qui est en ce
moment en discussion à l'assemblée
nationale c'est une voie de progrès
parce que chaque fois que l'on pourra
organiser différemment d'un certain
nombre de secteurs ouvrir des
professions permettre la concurrence
introduire des possibilités pour des
jeunes de créer leur propre activité
favoriser l' épargne salariale favoriser
la prise de responsabilité oui c'est
noah de progrès seynois qui permet aux
jeunes de retrouver confiance dans leur
avenir
j'ai indiqué les parts salariales parce
qu'elle est venue dans la discussion au
parlement
parce que une façon d'assurer que les
salariés et les employeurs bénéficient
ensemble je dis bien ensemble de la
réussite c'est aussi la participation et
l'intéressement
le forfait social sera donc module est à
la baisse au service des objectifs de
créer plus d épargne salariale et de
l'investir davantage dans les
entreprises le deuxième objectif pour la
modernisation de notre économie c'est
l'attractivité
je salue ici la présence dans cette
salle de dirigeants de 80 filiales de
groupes étrangers installés en france
ils sont ici pour la première fois et je
veux leur dire notre confiance mais
aussi salué la confiance qu'ils
accordent à notre économie
je sais qu'il ya toujours des débats
lorsqu'à l'investissement étranger se
fait en france est-ce que c'était pas
une perte d'indépendance et pourtant
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises
investissent à l'étranger
chaque fois qu'elles le font c'est un
succès que nous seulement parce que nous
savons qu'il va y avoir un courant des
changes
chaque fois que l'on peut avoir des
capitaux qu'ils puissent venir en france
créer de l'activité créer de l'emploi
n'ont pas décollé délocaliser des
activités mais au contraire en créer une
nouvelle
c'est un atout pour notre pays
d'ailleurs dans la compétition mondiale
chaque grande nation essaye tente
d'accueillir des investissements
étrangers comme d'ailleurs chaque grande
nation doit être dans la mondialisation
capable d'aller s'installer dans les
pays émergents pour créer un flux
d'activité au bénéfice de l'emploi dans
notre pays et on sait qu'il ya des
relations directes entre un
investissement étranger est une création
d'emplois dans notre pays
de la même manière qu'il y a un rapport
direct entre un investissement français
qui se fait à l'étranger est une
création d'emplois dès lors que ce n'est
pas fondé sur une délocalisation
simplement pour des coûts de travail
plus faible alors nous devons aussi
changer nos méthodes et notre
organisation
l'état l'a fait avec une nouvelle agence
business france qui créé par la fusion
de deux organismes que vous connaissez
bien la fille est uni france et ça ne
donnera plus de capacité pour intervenir
pour accompagner pour créer de l'emploi
le régime fiscal de ce qu'on appelle les
impatriés a été amélioré pour qu'il y
ait de nouveaux talents qui viennent en
france sans qu'il y ait besoin que des
talents français partent à l'étranger
même si ça fait aussi partie de la loi
du monde
des engagements précis ont été pris pour
assurer la sécurité des investissements
en france en proscrivant la
rétroactivité fiscale qui est en dedans
de la clarté sans remettre en cause nos
règles et nos systèmes de prélèvements
voilà ce que nous avons fait pour que
notre économie soit attractive et
qu'elles puissent créer davantage
d'emplois
mais il ya une règle simple que nous
partageons tous au delà de nos
différences
une économie d'être attractive que si
elle est innovante que si elle est
meilleure en termes de savoir faire en
termes de technologie en termes d'
inventions en termes aussi de formation
de ses salariés
l'innovation c'est la clef de tout ici
sont présentes également 86 entreprises
qui ont figuré cette année dans le
classement des 500 startups en plus
forte croissance au monde je dis bien au
monde pour la troisième année
consécutive c'est une entreprise
française qui est en tête de ce
classement international
oui parce qu'il ya une fierté aussi
avoir dans la réussite de nos
entreprises
quelle fierté nous avons ressenti tous
sur les valeurs de la république
quelle fierté à être le pays de la
liberté même si ça a des conséquences
graves
même si ce n'est pas toujours compris
c'est une fierté que de pouvoir avoir
les plus grands talents sur le plan
culturel d'avoir les équipements qui
correspondent à une ambition la nôtre
d'être un pays de rayonnement
international
c'est une fierté d'avoir une langue
française qui est parlé par près de 300
millions de personnes dans le monde
c'est une fierté d'avoir une politique
internationale qu'ils soient respectés
d'avoir une armée qui nous assure aussi
notre sécurité
c'est une fierté d'avoir des
fonctionnaires qui assurent les services
publics le plus essentiel c'est une
fierté d'avoir des entreprises qui
réussissent taza les entreprises qui
exportent qui innovent et qui sont
reconnus au plan international la france
elle est créative
depuis deux ans la nouvelle france
industrielle celle qui apparaît à
travers les projets que nous avons mis
en place des 34 projets
ce qui permet d'anticiper sur ce que
sera l'industrie de demain
il ya le projet usine du futur je sais
qu'il tient à coeur de beaucoup d'entre
vous qui rassemble les fédérations de la
mécanique de l'électronique de la
robotique du numérique qui rassemble des
entreprises de toute taille pme comme
pays et qui va permettre à l'industrie
française de faire son tournant du
numérique en 2015 y aura des projets
phares qui vont de nouveau être
présentés véhicule autonome sera la
première expérimentation sur août au 1er
septembre prochain
l'avion électrique il volera au dessus
de la manche
au printemps les objets connectés ils
vont être mis en place dès cette année
nous avons aussi lancé un grand concours
c'était en 2013 avec la commission
lauvergeon pour l'innovation
il y à déjà plus de 200 projets qui ont
été retenus
il y aura une deuxième vague qui va être
lancé au mois de mars
en juin je réunirai les nouvelles
assises de l'entrepreneuriat qui seront
consacrés à la création à l'innovation
et au financement
parallèlement des mesures de
simplification ont été prises 250 et ce
n'est pas encore assez
parce que chaque jour j'ai des
témoignages de la complexité pour
beaucoup d'entreprises n'ont pas par
rapport au droit social non pas par
rapport au droit environnemental mais
simplement aussi par rapport à ce que
demande l'administration
donc nous avons décidé d'aller loin
aussi loin que possible
la mission poitrinal quand guillaume est
en place un secret d'état a été dédiée à
cette responsabilité et il y en a encore
dans les jours qui viennent
plusieurs mesures qui seront prises dans
la loi macron il y en a aussi qui vont
permettre d'être appliquée dès à présent
le numérique c'est aussi une condition
de cette modernisation le numérique va
bouleverser toute notre société dans les
années qui viennent
le rapport au travail les modes de
consommation s'est déjà fait des
modifications profondes aussi dans la
consommation dans la production
dans l'environnement tout ça est à neuf
il ya aussi la protection des libertés
qui doit être assurée protection des
données personnelles
même si nous avons aussi à faire en
sorte que la sécurité soit assurée c'est
toujours le partage que les données
personnelles puissent être protégés et
qu'en même temps que nous puissions être
tous protégés
donc le numérique va être aussi la
priorité de l'europe parce que quand
même en europe
ces 28 pays 28 autorités de régulation
quant aux états unis il y en a qu'une ça
facilite les choses
28 autorités de régulation c'est
empêchent d'avoir un grand marché et ça
permet d'ailleurs à d'autres à des
opérateurs
venant notamment des états unis pas
seulement des états unis d'être présent
sur notre économie on en tirant tous les
profits et sans en payer en termes
d'impôts la contribution
la grande affaire du monde pour l'année
qui va s'achever en 2015 en descend ce
sera la conférence sur le climat
notre pays doit montrer l'exemple il
doit faire émerger une économie plus
sobre plus propre - ad moins dépendante
du carbone et des énergies fossiles
je vous le dis franchement c'est une
opportunité pour nos entreprises pour
nos ingénieurs pour nos inventeurs parce
que nous sommes meilleurs dans beaucoup
de domaines dans beaucoup de secteurs
notamment les technologies de
l'environnement mais également les
transports la construction l'agriculture
la filière bois nous sommes meilleurs
que beaucoup de pays qui pensent être en
pointe sur ces questions et donc nous
devons par rapport à l'enjeu même faire
que nos objectifs puissent être atteints
lors de la conférence sur le climat
préparer l'économie de demain la loi sur
la transition énergétique va donner des
moyens nouveaux va permettre que des
filières puisse s'organiser notamment
dans le renouvelable
si on gardait aussi sur le plan du
nucléaire une perspective qui permet
moderniser nos centrales et de réduire
la part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité nous allons aussi faire en
sorte qu' il puisse y avoir j'évoquais
la filière bois mais il y en a bien
d'autres que nous puissions avoir des
technologiques qu'ils soient parmi les
meilleurs du monde l'agriculture
française va être par la transition
énergétique soutenu davantage notamment
sur le plan européen
voilà les grands enjeux qui vont
mobiliser des forces vives de la nation
et l'ensemble des pouvoirs publics
mesdames et messieurs vous représenter
la diversité de nos forces économiques
et de notre représentation sociale vous
êtes des travailleurs des patrons des
français il ya ici des étrangers aussi
il ya des pme il y à des entreprises de
taille intermédiaire la chance de la
france et il y à des multinationales des
grands groupes qui sont aussi des
leaders dans le monde
vous êtes toute la diversité de notre
économie et l'économie marchande
l'économie également solidaire
l'économie sociale qui occupe 10 % de
nos emplois dans notre pays il y à issy
de l'agriculture au transport des
services à l'industrie
tout ce qui fait la richesse la
diversité de notre économie mais à pays
n'avance que si il est rassemblé que
s'il est capable de conjuguer ces
différences plutôt que d'en faire des
sujets de division c'est vrai sur le
plan économique c'est vrai sur le plan
politique mais les économies qui
stagnent les économies qui décline ce
sont en fait les économies où il n'y a
plus de projet collectif
il n'ya plus d'ambition nationale où il
ya plus d'idéal partagé
c'est un risque pour une économie je
trouve que l'économie française est une
économie qui va connaître aussi une
stimulation par la démographie française
c'est pour ça que je suis attaché aussi
à la politique familiale
à l'horizon 2050 la france va être le
pays le plus peuplé d'europe plus
peuplée que l'allemagne
nous avons une démographie qui nous fait
si je puis dire contrainte aujourd'hui
où il faut créer des emplois alors que
la population active augmente mais c'est
une chance
l'économie française va être simulés par
tout ce qui fait la force d'une jeunesse
la vitalité d'une population à nous
d'être au rendez vous alors ce qui vient
de se produire dans notre pays nous crée
une obligation une obligation de nous
élever de nous dépasser de nous m
chacune chacun à notre meilleur niveau
j'ai dit notre fierté
ça a été de défendre des valeurs de la
république mais notre fierté ça doit
être aussi d'avoir une économie solide
et forte et de belles de grandes
entreprises comme de petites premier
ministre aura aussi avec le gouvernement
mercredi prochain sous mon autorité à
prendre des décisions pour la sécurité
de notre pays moi même je réunirai un
conseil de défense pour que nous
puissions faire en sorte que notre armée
puisse répondre aux menaces qui existent
nous aurons également sur l'éducation à
faire en sorte que nos enseignants
puissent être accompagné soutenu par
rapport aux défis qu'ils rencontrent aux
tâches que leur demande de faire et
d'accomplir alors que ce n'est pas
toujours le rôle de l'école que
d'éduquer 6 mai de donner des références
aux enfants c'est drôle aussi des
familles donc nous allons prendre des
décisions mais ce que nous devons aussi
faire toujours faire c'est de permettre
à notre économie d'être plus dynamique
qu'il y ait plus de croissance plus
d'emploi clos puissions lutter contre le
chômage et favoriser l'intégration de
tous et ce défi là c'est une
responsabilité collective et ce qui
relève de l'état du gouvernement ici
rassemblés
et puis il y a ce qui appartient aux
partenaires sociaux
il y a des intérêts différents dans
cette salle forcément et les
sensibilités aussi différentes
oui il ya une cause une cause qui nous
rassemble tous c'est la cohésion de
notre pays
alors c'était une cérémonie de voeux
elle prend un caractère forcément
différent aujourd'hui
mais le seul voeu que je veux formulées
aujourd'hui c'est que nous puissions
nous rassembler prendre des décisions
être à la hauteur de nos responsabilités
pour donner une force à notre pays ait
un sens à ce que nous faisons pour que
nos concitoyens puissent se sentir
réunis dans une seule nation une seule
nation une seule france un seul peuple
qui doit être conscient que notre
économie est aujourd'hui aussi une
condition de sa cohésion
merci
vous avez donc privé en direction des
chaînes parlementaires les voeux de
françois hollande aux acteurs de
l'entreprise et de l'emploi nous allons
revenir sur ce discours de françois
hollande avec jean louis gombeaud notre
spécialiste économique et mickaël szames
est ce notre spécialiste politique alors
michael un discours de plus de 45
minutes que françois hollande a commencé
et terminé en évoquant ce qui s'était
passé en france ces derniers jours
c'était le fil conducteur de tout son
discours à françois hollande on a eu
c'est vrai beaucoup de choses tout ce
qui a été fait sur l'économie de 2014 à
2015 on a entendu beaucoup de chiffres
comme d'habitude il est parti dans les
détails de chaque mesure pour expliquer
mais tout au long de son discours
on a entendu ces mots unité va leur
fierté fierté d'être français fierté de
ce que vous représentez la liberté ne
peut savoir aussi que en fonction de la
croissance la liberté la sécurité le
rassemblement il a encore dit à la fin
de son discours une nation un pays une
force
en fait il a pris à témoin les acteurs
de l'entreprise en leur disant
aujourd'hui vous êtes face à vos
responsabilités vous avez des accords à
trouver où vous avez des choses à faire
pour que ce pays soit ensemble une force
une valeur et puis il ya aussi le
travail qui est fait par les politiques
mais sans ses deux travaillent sans ces
deux travaux que ce soit du politique et
des facteurs économiques
la france ne pourra pas être unis
finalement ce qu'il a voulu faire
c'était sûr fait quelque part sur cet
esprit du 11 janvier qui voulait
absolument préserver expliqué aussi que
sans cet esprit là on ne pourrait pas
trouver les chemins de la croissance il
a voulu un petit peu se grandir aussi
françois hollande car il a il l'a dit
lui même on doit s'élever se dépasser
dépasser la fonction et puis quelque
part aussi l'a voulu donner confiance
espoir au lendemain de tout ce qui s'est
passé en france
il a essayé de redonner un petit peu
d'espoir et de confiance et dynamisme à
l'économie au pays et jean-louis il a
voulu impliquer en ces acteurs de
l'entreprise et de l'emploi françois
hollande il leur a dit vous êtes au
coeur de la nation il les a appelés à
être à la hauteur de la réaction des
français après les attentats la hauteur
de l'unité nationale alors en prenant
d'ailleurs un exemple dix ans une partie
très simple c'est le dialogue social
c'est à dire que visuellement droit en
plus de tout ce qu'a dit michael je
crois que le dialogue social était le
fil conducteur de tous
son propre os iliaques social lié aux
questions de l'unité en disant bien
écouté jeudi prochain vous vous
réunissez pour disons mettre en place
ils ont les nouvelles structures la
nouvelle architecture dialogue social en
france
vous ne pouvez pas échouer il faut
absolument savait qu'un échec serait
lourd de conséquences
l'échec il est déjà patent puisqu'il ça
devait être conclue à la fin de la
semaine dernière visiblement ça ne l'est
pas et il les a poussés dans ce qu'a dit
le président je vois de plusieurs choses
d'abord il ya un aspect que je
qualifierais court et moyen terme
ce qu'on appelle la conjoncture vous
avez tout en main pour faire de la
croissance et pour faire de l'emploi
regarder la conjoncture internationale
certes il y à des sortes de difficultés
par exemple il dit les pays émergents il
cite notamment la chine ralentisse
certes nous avons des problèmes du côté
de l'est de l'europe et ce qui nous pose
de sacrés problèmes en matière agricole
et autres mais si vous prenez l'ensemble
des choses l'euro le pétrole les taux
d'intérêt vous avez là de quoi avoir
confiance
ne soyez pas timoré il y a n'ayez pas
peur de la conjoncture qui vient dire
qu'effectivement si vous pensez que tout
va se dégrader devant vous et bien
effectivement vous free au lac la
conjoncture devient frileuse avec les
économistes dit souvent il suffit que
les chefs d'entreprise sortent avec un
parapluie pour qu'ils se mettent à
pleuvoir
effectivement il ya des oc et des
anticipations négatives
ça se déroule dans la conjoncture donc
là et c'est voulu dans un premier temps
rassurant puis après il ya une deuxième
partie du propos du président sur des
voeux à plus long terme c'est à dire si
tu es la france dans un processus plus
long c'est à dire de modernisation
innovation attractivité etc etc
en prenant à chaque fois un certain
nombre d'exemples donc la conclusion de
tout ça c'est malgré les vicissitudes
malgré le drame vous pouvez avoir
confiance dans l'avenir
maintenant il faut se mettre au travail
nous mettons en place tout un tout un
dispositif
le pacte de stabilité qui arriva le
premier jeu qui est arrivé le 1er
janvier la nouvelle l'histoire de la
formation qui arrive le 1er janvier tout
est en place on retrouve un petit peu
d'une manière un peu différente
ceux qui le disaient sur la boîte à
outils est donc reconduit
amy d'autres choses encore dans ma boîte
à outils vous êtes on a tous maintenant
pour réussir il faut reste à le
démontrer
quel est le message je sais qu'elle
voulait faire passer françois hollande
c'est que en 2015 la priorité serait
certes la sécurité mais ce serait encore
et toujours l'emploi mais l'emploi
évidemment la croissance ou l'emploi
tout est mis en place pour que
aujourd'hui l'emploi soit au rendez vous
on a mis plusieurs choses en place des
propositions qui ont été formulées
depuis 2014 jusqu'à 2015 jusqu'au cice
qui rentrent en place en vigueur jaune
tout ça c'est fait pour l'emploi la
croissance car sans la croissance sans
emploi effectivement le pays est en
danger
le pays est en danger parce que il fait
appel à deux portes ouvertes à tous les
déclinistes à tous ceux qui disent que
la france n'est plus la france et que
forcément ça agitent les peurs donc s'il
ya de l'emploi il ya moins de peur plus
de sécurité
voilà ce que voilà ce qu'elle essayait
d'expliquer le françois hollande
maintenant ça ne veut pas dire que ça
puisse arriver est mise en place il ya
tout table c'est ça aussi qu'il faudra
voir dans les prochains mois si jamais
on n'a pas les résultats économiques
escomptées
forcément les définissent pour reprendre
le cours j'en veux vous parler du pacte
de responsabilité françois hollande l'a
bien sûr évoqué il a appelé à accélérer
la marche mais il a aussi rappelé qu'un
pacte suppose des contreparties alors
oui il a donné d'ailleurs un chiffre
c'est contrepartie on en parlait juste
avant l'émission il a dit il ya onze
branches maintenant qu'ils ont signé
pour avoir des contreparties
effectivement c'est à l'heure actuelle
c'est archi minoritaire vu le nombre de
branches qui existent en france donc il
est appelé à ses contreparties mais je
pense qu'il n'a pas trop insisté là
dessus nous allons baisser les charges
des entreprises de l'ordre de 40
milliards le cic a déjà commencé dans
l'année 2014 nous poursuivons avec le
pacte en 2015 ça va s'accentuer il est
pour poursuivre un peu ce que faisait
michael en fin de compte on parle de
l'esprit du 11 janvier
le président a dit encore s je crois que
c'était dit hier ou avant l'année
c'était samedi il a dit que rien ne sera
comme avant c'est à dire prenez
conscience de ça c'est à dire que quel
est votre responsabilité par rapport à
cette affaire du 12 janvier au fait que
plus rien ne sera comme avant
ce quelle est votre part qu'elle comment
vous y prendre
part dans cette histoire et bien c'est
justement en donnant un dynamisme à
l'économie qui est quand même un aspect
un aspect du problème qui nous est posée
et donc nous et j'ai mis en place
il a répété tout ce qu'il avait été mis
en place comme l'a dit à leurs michael
et je vais renforcée sur les emplois
d'avenir
le contrat de génération il a donné
quelques chiffres qui montrent qu'il va
amplifier cette affaire vous avez tout
en main pour participer de votre côté à
ce que j'ai appelé l'esprit du 11
janvier
j'ai enlevé le président a également
parlé de l'union européenne il a appelé
l'union européenne à plus d'initiatives
et il a aussi évoqué ce qu'on va faire
la bce jeudi qui va injecter des
liquidités dans la zone euro c'est une
première un jean louis et expliquez nous
en quoi ça consiste
c'est la bonne alors il a appelé
évidemment le plus important ce que vous
dites sur la bce il a cité la question
européenne à deux niveaux le plan
juncker d'investissement 350 milliards
d'euros
qui pour l'instant est aidant dans les
cartons enfin il est par contre ce qui
va être très important pour jeudi
prochain
c'est cette initiative nouvelle qui est
dans les textes contraire quand même aux
traités européens où la bce devrait
s'engager il
il avait l'air très affirmatif pour
l'instant c'est un une information qui
courent mais en fait la décision d pas
formellement prise même si monsieur
draghi l'a laissé entendre la la banque
centrale européenne va désormais pouvoir
acheter en direct directement elle peut
le faire dès d'ores et déjà
indirectement par l'intermédiaire des
banques commerciales
mais elle va acheter en direct des
obligations souveraines il a dit nous
appelons ça dans le langage public
d'obligations publiques d'obligations
d'état c'est à dire que un état qui a du
mal à se financer est bien là mais ce va
pouvoir lui acheter des obligations et
ça c'est tout à fait tu es tout à fait
nouveau parce que dans les traités il
est interdit à la banque centrale
européenne de procéder à de tels achats
et effectivement c'est ses achats de
dette publique
ça va donner de la liquidité
supplémentaire en quantité d'ailleurs
importante on n'en connaît pas les
chiffres qu'il devrait normalement
pouvoir serait
injectés dans l'économie européenne donc
ils annoncent quelque chose
d'extrêmement important qui se passera
jeudi qui est extrêmement important sur
le plan institutionnel
sur le plan politique et sur le plan
économique qui devrait être favorable à
la croissance
michael d'un moment très rapidement il
reste 30 secondes france hollande a
également parlé du service civique et
annoncé un objectif de 100 mille
volontaires en 2004 et on parle beaucoup
du service militaire la droite voudrait
revoir le service militaire et
visiblement service civique avec cent
mille personnes sur 1000 volontaires
pour 2015 150 milles d'ici 2017
encore un petit point il a pas parlé de
la loi macro c'est en ce moment en
discussion à la commission silence radio
il a laissé la parole à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est en débat chez les
parlementaires
il a effectivement il sait pas la loma
coin qui sera examiné à l'assemblée à
partir de lundi prochain lundi 26
janvier merci à tous les deux d'avoir
été avec nous pour suivre ce discours de
françois hollande demain à 9h30
nous suivrons est les voeux de françois
hollande aux parlementaires et aux corps
constitués
merci à tous et très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires